hello hello hello this week is an
absolute belter this genuinely could be
the best podcast I've done so far really
really happy with it
doctor you and Lawson is my guest he is
the author of the healthy writer also a
general practitioner of Medicine in the
UK and the host of the below ecology
podcast checked out on iTunes stitcher
all those good places and today we are
talking about what it's like working at
a desk so very very high proportion of
people will spend at least a significant
period of their week sat down working a
desk looking at a screen what we try to
go through today is with the help of dr.
Lawson's expertise is to break down
exactly what is good and bad practice
when it comes to designing your
workstation so we're talking from
seating posture height of screen cranial
angle looking down but angle for your
wrists what you can do about reducing
RSI what you can do about reducing
stress on your eyes improving your sleep
your work rhythms how you can use some
productivity tools and some productivity
hacks to batch together your work into
Windows so that you're always
accountable to yourself and so that you
can improve your productivity we go into
journaling we go into the health effects
of sitting of being sedentary this
really is absolutely jam-packed and I'm
incredibly happy with it also I have to
say the long-awaited love island podcast
is now available and it will be a
YouTube exclusive for the foreseeable
future
so if you wanted to hear what it's
really like living on love island with
me Johnny and Youssef you have to go
online head to youtube and search modern
wisdom podcast it'll come up the
response has been fantastic we've broken
through I think 3k views maybe already
really really happy with about loads
messages about it so make sure they had
online if you love the podcast on audio
every episode will be made available on
YouTube as well now and I'm going to be
uploading video files for all of the old
ones including all subsequent episodes
as well make sure you had their press
subscribe and please support the channel
but now it's time for doctor you and
Lawson enjoy make some notes and
hopefully you will wake up tomorrow with
a fresh set of eyes before you go to
work
[Music]
dr. yu and lawson welcome to modern
wisdom hello Chris how are you very well
thank you and yourself yeah very good
thank you so I put a post out on my
Instagram earlier today and I said do
you work a desk do you suffer with any
physical ailments or repetitive strain
injury neck pain back pain tight hips
and my inbox absolutely exploded I think
I could have announced that I was
getting married or having a child and
would have probably got less of a
response and yeah the the problem of
working at a desk and sitting looking at
a computer seems to be so widespread and
it was it was a real a real shock to me
just how many people for one of a better
term kind of suffering in silence
dealing with it as a byproduct of well
this is work and the same ways going
down the coal mine you know however many
years ago would have been oh well you
know this is just it's just a an issue
that comes along with the particular
chosen industry that I'm in why do you
think that the use of desk work is so
widespread but the optimization of it
and the making of it to be a healthy
environment doesn't seem to be and I
guess the whole kind of I think you're
right it's a bit of a modern plague
isn't it there people are absolutely
just getting increasingly aware of their
pain it's putting them through it I
guess the problems are the economics and
things have been known for a long time
but I wonder if it's just a case of us
you know it's a bit there's a bit of
catching up to do you're in that sort of
phase where it's become the social norm
to look at a computer all the time and
if you think about it it's only you know
it's only 10 20 years ago we didn't have
little screens to look at the iPhone was
only invent I've had only appeared you
know a decade ago ever it was it's a
really short period of time isn't it
yeah and so that the health-related
consequences of doing looking at screens
all the time looking at computers that a
screen time has just gone through the
roof in the last few years and I don't
think the healthy kind of approaches to
have quite caught up yet perhaps yeah no
I think that's
I think that's definitely definitely an
issue that you've got the industry being
a head of the research to a degree or at
least the distribution of it and
people's understanding so hopefully
today we can start to mitigate some of
those problems yeah sure
people may be waking up tomorrow with a
fresh set of eyes as they go into work
so can you run can you give us a little
bit of background to yourself please for
the listeners who yeah you are so um I'm
a I'm a doctor I'm a GP so general
practitioner and for those of them those
of the people not based in the kind of
UK or Australia New Zealand other places
the GP is just a kind of like a
specialist in family medicine so it's
cradle to the grave stuff we see people
before they get to hospital from
children to adults to kind of palliative
care end-of-life stuff as well so yeah
very much kind of the full spectrum of
health problems and we also spend a lot
of time looking after people and prevent
there's a certain element of
preventative health and managing people
helping people with lifestyle things
like obesity or other smoking other
related factors like that I have I was
in the army a few years ago I've always
had an interest in being physically
healthy of course but I like everybody
up had my own set of you know wrestling
with these kind of problems spending too
much time sitting at a desk or trying to
lose a little bit of weight trying to be
active in a world that is determined to
get us to eat more all the time yeah and
that's one of my big moans about the
modern world is how it's constantly it's
certainly in the Western world where the
society is pretty much RAM food down our
throats yes 99 percent of the time
wrestling with all that trying to keep
fit trying to kind of maintain family
life not trying to get burned out trying
to stay fit and well so that that's my
own personal interest and my obviously
aligns with my personal and my
professional life as well as a as a
doctor yeah and I I was involved in
writing a book last year with them
Johanna Pina got a well-known creative
entrepreneur and nonfiction fiction
writer I'm a book called the healthy
writer where we and it was very much
written for writers and for that group
of people but I think probably a lot of
the stuff in there's applicable to
anyone who finds themselves parked in
front of a computer for their working
life absolutely not getting active
enough and they just want to do
something about it
yeah I agree I think that's I wouldn't
like to guess the the percentage of
people but a large majority of almost
everyone will spend over 15 20 hours a
week at sort of towards the bottom end
and then you're talking if you work in a
call center if you're a knowledge worker
of pretty much any kind
it's that thirty seven and a half hours
a week it's probably thirty seven hours
at a screen yeah it's insane and I mean
the I mean does the actual physical
effect of just being sat there but it's
just the fact you're not moving as well
that kind of and it falls in it's now
become slightly a cliche that sitting is
the new smoking and there's kind of a
lot people have heard that in the last
few years but I think that kind of lack
of movement that's and you know the
sedentary life that's a massively toxic
I think just just I'll just strive to
visit and I think it's certainly been
that some of the evidence around this is
hard to pick out actually I guess that's
my other interests that I'm really
intricately delving into the evidence
and not just kind of putting out that
you know kind of vague opinion and yeah
I recognize the importance of anecdotes
as well you know instead extent
everybody that comes in to see you as a
patient as and you know there are then
individual and evident those problems
with applying evidence to individuals
that's it that's the challenge of being
a doctor it it's hard to put a number on
it because sometimes the relationship
between sitting and pure health isn't
completely demonstrable it's not
completely easy to show and it's a
little bit contradictory in places so I
would you would struggle to quantify it
I think what it's easier to show is that
people who are physically active enjoy
longer life better quality of life and a
whole lot of other kind of measurements
that go with that in terms of their risk
of the cardiovascular disease diabetes
they're all massively improved by being
active and it's harder to prove that
just sitting as an activity is actually
bad for you yeah I think I think it's
the general attitude the general sort of
the whole picture of your house add
entry you are that's really important
yeah for sure
I think certainly for myself I I could
probably hold my hands up and say that I
know I trained very hard when I do and
go and do physical activity but I also
know that I'm very sedentary other
points as well yeah and I think I've
probably kidded myself into believing
for quite a while that well it's fine
I'm I'm looking after my activity levels
across the day therefore if I spend
three hours at a period in between
toilet breaks sitting at my desk and not
moving and staring at screen that's fine
because the physical effect will be
mitigated by me
pinning myself in a two hour CrossFit
session or whatever it might be yeah
yeah wrong way to look at it no no
actually there is I looked into this a
little bit for the book as well and
there's something that you know that you
fall into that it's not a slight
category a weekend warrior though I
recognize it's not always just at the
weekends and there is there is some
evidence that if you do your exercise
batched up say at the weekend in that
classic weekend warrior kind of approach
that does seem to that does seem to be
helpful so you can mitigate some of the
harms of your rest of your week being
relatively inactive okay I think that
some of the difficulties you mentioned
coal miners at the start actually the
difficulty that is coal miners were
incredibly physically active they didn't
do any they didn't do any sitting down I
mean at least those that was one one
bonus to take away from it I suppose
yeah but they were incredibly good at
dying young for various reasons and but
if you look at senior executives thank
you your average CEO they spent their
whole life sitting down but they're sort
of societal level that they operate at
they're incredibly likely to have good
health outcomes as well so that's why
this sort of research around sitting and
longevity gets a little bit tricky in
places because you've got to take into
account all the other stuff like we're
smoking and drinking and exercise
generally yeah I think if you look at a
bit of one knot I've certainly saw one
academic paper which looked at all the
evidence and it certainly suggested that
sitting down and being inactive actually
cause deaths and so I think it's
reasonable to say sitting is killing
people well that kind of it's always as
Ben Goldacre would say it's it's always
a it's a so I think I find it's a little
bit more complicated there's always
complications around the edges but
being active and tackling the sitting is
clearly a massive priority for most
people yeah definitely so let us say
with this with this Instagram post that
I fired out earlier on yeah I got a
whole host of of common ailments and
there was an awful lot across there
awful lot of crossover it was probably a
fairly representative sample as well
there's about 120 messages so I've got
okay good a good sample size to work
from yeah I wanted to speak to yourself
first off and try and get any common
mistakes which people make when
designing a workstation and on the
backside of that what are the most
optimal fixes for them okay so I've not
ever seen any evidence of what the
mistakes people make but what I would
say is that the big the initial mistake
as most people don't make any effort to
design their workstation at all is the
receipt is there a table is there a lot
of yeah is there anybody else at there
no this will do that is probably the
approach and it's hot desking that's
certainly going to be the approach that
a lot of people have yeah well you can
do yeah yeah exactly you're just got to
turn up and plunk your butt down and you
know and if you get spare seat in the
library if you're a student then you're
happy and there's often the way it goes
so I'm not sure about specific mistakes
people make the kind of things that the
first thing I could perhaps talk about
is laptops and notebooks and I would say
they are kind of like the they are they
are talk via toxic equivalent
economically they are pretty horrific
and they they put you in all the wrong
position completely and using a laptop
and just typing on it without any kind
of effort to change it the position that
you're in could will throw a lot of
people be a source of a great deal of
problems okay so the first thing they do
is they they put your wrists all the
wrong angles and the ideal position for
your wrists is the not resting on
anything and probably at about sort of
parallel to the floor and 90 degrees to
your body so the only way you can fix
that normally is by adjusting the height
of your keyboard now if you're designing
a workstation then you can arrange for
your desk to be exactly the right height
yeah so that you can make that work for
your relative reasonably easy the best
way to fix it with a
top is not to use the keyboard on the
laptop is to get an external keyboard
okay and then because they're just not
you know you've got the mouse sat in
front of you it's awkward it tends to
your wrists end up contorted in the
wrong position so an external keyboard
is usually a really good investment
the next thing after that is that you're
probably always looking down at it if
it's a laptop and they're sure but
unless you're very small in stature
you're going to be you're always going
to be training down at your laptop and
so raising your laptop up so you're I
you so your necks in a neutral position
is the best way and that does mean it
needs to come up quite a bit yeah yeah
the the screen of a laptop is naturally
very low yeah am i right in thinking
that having that cranial angle being
more towards the floor will apply more
stress to I mean I think that's the
general thought I don't know kind of I'm
not an expert in ergonomics in that
regard but I certainly know that good
ergonomic practice is to have your neck
in a reasonably neutral position because
that which is generally just sort of
looking straight ahead I slightly down
possibly so eyes eyes level with the top
of the screen right yeah that works well
if your eyes are level with the top edge
then actually you're just looking very
slightly down at the screen itself
that's so that's usually a good way to
do it and that just stops your neck
muscles having to work as hard when
they're when you're in a normal position
so that's highly likely to relieve a lot
of problems and discomfort and you got
to remember even things like you know
tension headaches if your necks in the
wrong position and you're under a bit of
stress then a lot of headaches that we
certainly we see as a as a GP a lot of
headaches of tension headaches and
that's all related to muscular tension
in the back of the neck and where do you
one where detention headaches manifest
well they usually the classic
description is that they're a band
sometimes around the front of the head
sometimes around the back of the head
okay and they tend to be very they tend
to be much more constant not easily
relieved by medication as a general rule
I'm looking at two points that I've got
in my notes from messages I received
earlier on headaches across brow and
lower / back of skull okay so that you
know that is almost yeah so there you go
and then rehearse that at all no that's
exactly a classic description of a
tension headache okay and you have to
remember that there are must most of you
you can't have you only got to have a
briefest glance
the anatomy of the head and neck to see
that there are muscles that you know
they interlock all the way up around
your forehead the side of your head all
those muscles interlock and if you have
the end then the muscles in your neck
are under tension there's often a
knock-on effect that those muscles
across the front of your head and your
forehead are under tension and you end
up getting headaches okay so actually
getting your screen position right could
often deal with chronic headaches and
kind of tension headaches which is
incredibly useful so suppose if you've
gone Bluetooth Keyboard and let's say
that you are working at a notebook that
allows that allows you then to you could
get anything you could get a stack of
books you could get some yeah you could
get a proper stand I suppose that you
can put you put your laptop on but
freeing yourself up with keyboard and
mouse from being attached to the
notebook also enables you to get the
screen up in the air as well so you
killed - but you have one store
yeah exactly they're the two big things
you get an external keyboard and raise
up your laptop and you're right you
combine notebook risers and all that and
spend money on it I don't have one of
those I use I use when I'm in my office
I would just use three or four weighty
medical textbooks go underneath my
laptop and that just does the job very
nice they have an old keyboard from an
ancient iMac that I have plugged in with
a USB connection and a dead sheep mouse
and there they go I use my macbook with
those and that's I've you know it's much
more comfortable yeah I think I mean for
anyone who's listening I know that you
can get if you if you are a workflow
nerd as some of us are and you like you
like your gestures and stuff you multi
edge tools Apple do a partner trackpad
which is exactly the same as you would
get on your laptop on a macro or
something similar and it gives you the
opportunity to do all the same you can
get a you can actually get an expanded
version of the Apple keyboard as well
which is got the one to nine numpad on
the right-hand side as well so you can
actually end up with a better
functionality keyboard by taking it off
and down but you know to hear that you
use something yes maybe not from quite
from this century and you're still
you're still you're still saying that
it's it's a viable alternative
referable alternative that's a I think
reassuring someone that got some lying
around somewhere yeah I think sweep air
I think it's about 2003 that I max oh
yeah it wasn't it wasn't quite last
century but it's pretty damn close yeah
I there is that's a good point because I
do actually find that they struggle with
slightly when I use that is that I'm a
lot I'm used to using the gestures on
the touchpad so I do find that a bit
awkward but what I've tried very hard to
do and I've been doing this the last few
months is I'm trying to learn the
keyboard shortcuts so I don't use the
mouse at all because I actually think
that's a much better way to go anyway so
you don't go to the mouse and have to
start and it just you know in terms of
workflow it's more efficient just to use
the keyboard shortcuts anyway so I'm
working harder than this and so if
there's one of the co-hosts when we do
our normal shells youssef he'll be
listening
we'll be creaming in his pants right now
as he hears you talk about as he hears
you talk about keyboard shortcuts have
you used
Alfred before well no I know of Alfred
but I never have used Alfred actually no
sell it to me oh I mean it is just an
absolute game changer life hacks one or
four carefully it fully explains how far
down the Alfred rabbit hole myself and
yousuf of tumble but yeah you are right
one of the one of the main Judy Moo foo
who is a body builder and tricky but
also big into periodization for work and
training yeah he talks an awful lot
about never using the mouse he's got
everything is set up to swipe to move
between apps and you're totally correct
that the less that you can use the mouse
if you're looking at really dialing in
to be as efficient as possible with your
workflow getting off the mouse's is
great and a lot of people do get a bit
kind of you talk about discomfort I'm
sure a couple of people have probably
mentioned repetitive strain injury I
think you mentioned it's partly oh yeah
using the mouse is often a source of
enormous discomfort for some people who
get RSI wounds I guess it must I don't
know why exactly I guess it's any
repetitive movement particular when you
hold something you hold your arm you can
get our sigh anywhere in the body
technically yeah but I guess most people
get it in there they get it in their
hands wrists forearms or fine fine motor
movement with little bits of control and
sort of small stabilizations and stuff
like that I guess if you're doing that
seven or eight hours a day yeah I think
that's exactly and that's the kind of so
a lot people then suddenly you know it
becomes really uncomfortable and
distressing to keep on doing that and
that's exactly the kind of thing that
can trigger off a bit of RSI and some
people you you seem to have a pretty
good understanding of Verisign am i
right in thinking RS access to two
distinct types to it yeah can you can
you elaborate on that for me
yeah sure could I run that basically I'm
not sure I have a good understanding of
it in I'm not sure anybody has a good
understanding of it's the only thing I
would say if anyone if anyone does we're
relying on you yeah so I'm the person
who says there's two types RSI type one
is easy and they are the ones where
people do have a good understanding of
it and it's usually got a very distinct
diagnosis and the classic example is
carpal tunnel syndrome and lots of
people have heard of that it's where
they've kind of been the nerve that goes
through your wrist the median nerve
there's a little sort of tunnel of space
at the wrist there and for various
reasons that can happen things like
pregnancy it can happen for all sorts of
reasons that gets a little bit
pressurized that nerve and you get
symptoms that then go into your hand and
so there's a very with things like
carpal tunnel syndrome or certain
tenosynovitis whereas where you get an
inflammation the tendons going to your
thumb or other things there's a very
there's usually a very clear treatment
and you know there may be injections
there may be carpal tunnel syndrome you
can even go on to have operations and
releases um they're they're kind of the
ones that are relatively easy to manage
and as a GP we don't feel too stressed
by them because and the patient doesn't
feel - feels better because we can give
them a diagnosis yes and offer a
management plan that's in comparison to
RSI type - which is a whole world of
pain no no no in several respects
because it's Reena beulah s-- and it's
difficult to there's not a single cause
it just usually is when people get
numbness and discomfort and aches
maybe pins and needles and it isn't
really obviously reputable it kind of
maybe varies a little but it doesn't fit
into any of the nice distinct patterns
of these other kind of disorders like
carpal tunnel syndrome but can it
due to a repetitive action which could
be causing RSI one does that make sense
so it's yeah yeah yeah you you gotta be
you could be suffering with both
essentially yeah I think in many cases
it probably is due to some kind of
repetitive you know or various ongoing
stress or tension yeah that is the case
so you definitely could and yeah you
could definitely have them coexisting in
some shape or form the problem because
it's not a sort of a definite way of
managing it it makes it harder to offer
a definitive solution like a steroid
injection or a surgical operation that
you can do in carpal tunnel so it's a
bit frustrating for patients and it's
certainly a bit frustrating and for
doctors as well because you know you're
in the business of trying to help people
you can't work out what's what's wrong
or how to fix it no it's against um
tension between patients and doctors in
this is that you usually have to stop
what you're doing but I mean I agree
that that's the thing it depends how the
doctor phrases it of course yeah because
that generally goes down incredibly
badly yes you're generally you're either
working or if it was writers no no
writer wants to stop writing or it might
be something like work-related and
people can't stop doing it but I think
my general advice is it's not really so
much about stopping what you do but you
really have got to change up the way you
do things cool in order to get it to
resolve itself and if you're working at
keyboard yeah you know you're um flying
a desk in the day you've probably got to
alter how you do um
you said you got to watch your workplace
but I think some of the answers are a
little bit more holistic and a bit more
widespread as well yeah and certainly
Joanna in the book the healthy writer
goes through this that actually I think
she tried a whole lot of which she got
RSI very badly and she's a really good
kind of case report in this regard that
actually she tried all the different
Mouse's the keyboards all of that and it
didn't make any difference and what in
the end fix there was a whole body
approach and she a yoga right yeah yoga
and I totally fix that and I think
that's the thing if you get your core
strength improved you start to get you
prove your posture generally you know it
might address tension issues as well
from stress and anxiety actually then
that might be the solution I think it
feels like you're reading my notes off
my screen at the moment I swear to the
listeners that you're not I'd split up
optimizing your workstation into two
categories one of which was solutions
when you're there and in other words
solutions when you're not yeah and I
think as you say there it needs to be
married with the two if even if you
optimize your workstation but when you
go home that you're sedentary at home
and you're not like you say you're not
building up any core stabilization
you're not getting your heart rate up
you're not getting any fresh air yeah
well all of these sort of things are
gonna lead to a problem on either side
and they both need to be looked after
right yeah absolutely
I I couldn't agree more and I suspect
it's far far more important than
actually the workplace stuff all that
stand you get so many other benefits as
well but you can sort of imagine why a
consultation with a doctor might go
badly because you turn up complaining
you're painting your wrists and you
doctor tell you to go and do a bit more
walking or exercise you've been really
good but actually I really do think it
is so you got out of those conversations
very carefully that's not to make people
understand but I think actually it's a
massive part of it and going right back
to what you said at the start I suspect
this is the kind of thing that you know
10 years 20 years in the future the
workplaces will do automatically that
actually there'll be regular breaks
there'll be opportunities to stretch to
walk get away from the screen and rather
than sitting in a call center eight
hours straight whatever it is actually
there will be requirements - yeah kind
of to build in proper breaks so we've
we've touched on it there I'm going to
I'm gonna unload the he the
meta-analysis that my very very well
conducted Instagram research okay and
then we're gonna try and design how
someone could have a good working
practice when the side desks oh yeah
tight hips back pain both upper and
lower neck pain the headache across
their brow and the lower back of the
skull difficulty in opening up the chest
from being in that anterior folded
forward shoulder
yeah and a pain or weakness in between
the shoulder blades which presumably is
from the same from not sitting with that
open chest fashion if you were to try
and design someone's working day so
we've got their keyboard down off the
computer potentially an external mouse
as well we've managed to lift the
cranial angle up by raising the height
of the display what are we going to do
next with regards to a seating posture
what about working rhythms work rest and
stuff like that during work what can be
done to assist in mitigating these
problems yeah I think there's some basic
stuff around seating posture you can do
which is just I mean we're obviously
talking seating at the moment rather
than standing or anything else more
exotic because that's simply not an
option for most people it's just simple
stuff there actually I mean I guess
you're getting your feet on the ground
is a massive thing when you're sitting
down indicating you get yourself in a
nice neutral position rather than your
legs being stretched out and that kind
of changes the position of your lower
back and flattens out that can a normal
curve that you have in your spine is
actually sitting on your six actual sit
bones getting your feet flat on the
ground okay and then trying to and
obviously some of that then is about
being aware of your posture and as you
mentioned they're about they're kind of
the not opening up the chest is dropping
your shoulders making sure they're nice
and relaxed I think just spending a few
minutes every look that we could talk
about the rhythm of this but actually
trying to build awareness whether it's
every 2025 minutes running through a
little self check about what is my
posture like at the moment and trying to
and trying to adjust it as you go is the
kind of thing that you do regularly can
start to become automatic and you
actually improve improve your general
posture yes
and I mean I think in terms of rhythm
that that sort of breaks is critical
more than anything how taking a break is
absolutely essential and my mom my
personal approach to this is when I'm in
a big block of writing or sitting at the
computer is I tend to use the sort of
Pomodoro method anyway because I find
that quite effective but it works really
well we're taking breaks so 25 minutes
of work set a timer on the watch buzzes
and then I get up and I take five
minutes off and during that five minute
so almost I will make sure it get up and
I'll walk around have a bit of a you
know and just get myself away from the
screen as well
yeah good to help my eyes which we can
also mention yeah to help with that and
I find that that really makes a huge
difference
the key for me that about the taking
breaks is and the thing I would mention
to people and this fit is that you've
got to get away from the screen if you
can yeah you know taking a break does
not mean pushing the chair back moving
further away from the screen or cursor
to the screen or looking at your looking
at your phone looking at a difference
and it's checking you know check-in
Instagram and Facebook that's not
another screen while you kind of
slumping and in your slump in your chair
that was really I'll take a brand
effective think I'll take a break from
my newly refined posture to slouch in my
seat put my my head a 90 degree angle to
the floor and sneak a quick look at my
phone instead yeah exactly
but that's not what we're prescribing
here yeah and I think you know most
people listening would think wow of
course I wouldn't do that but I mean
done yourself so actually taking taking
particular breaks something most people
know but actually it's putting it into
action as well isn't it like all these
things and actually doing it properly so
you give yourself an actual genuine
chance of proving I find if I do it I
can sustain much longer working periods
at twenty five minutes five minutes I
can do three or four hours of solid work
in the morning and actually don't feel
completely ruined by it I agree I think
there's a it's a short-term sacrifice of
work obviously by taking the five minute
break but the total volume that you get
the total tire effective time under the
curve of work done by the end of the day
will always be higher yeah it's
interesting that you mentioned the
Pomodoro Technique which I am currently
reading the illustrated guide to the
Pomodoro Technique in a desperate
attempt to try and make my work my work
life a little bit more optimal but be
focused Pro for anyone who's listening
is a
an app for Mac she's very very light and
it does exactly that it allows you to
work on one task at a time he sat a
timer for 25 minutes and then wants it
up it goes to a five-minute break and
tells you right now go away for five
minutes and then come back and I think
that so during those five minutes what
people doing walk to the water cooler
check the toilet sort of yeah
look look out the window yeah there's
yeah I mean there's a certain thing
about ice training about looking out the
window there's a kind of a bit of advice
which is the 20-20-20 technique fries
drain which is every 20 minutes take a
break and look out the window sort of
focus on something 20 feet away for 20
seconds I think if you're taking a
natural break every five minutes and
just you know changing the focal length
of where your eye is eyes are
concentrated that's really helpful and
that can be helpful in relieving eye
strain yeah so you can get some benefit
from that as well but I think they're
just the moving around is the key thing
if you you know oh yeah absolutely I do
that I get up have a stretch day I'm
working in the library of the office go
out have a look at the window walk up
and down the steps well you know a few
minutes that try not to get engaged in
any conversations yeah got five minutes
get that five minutes gonna turn into
twenty five minutes yeah exactly and the
key is just kind of a few minutes try to
think about something else completely
and then actually back to it and it's
and I just saved in the time under the
curve you end up far more productive and
I find it really helps me focus as well
because that 25 minutes is a relatively
short period and so I know that I will
give my all to that one task for 25
minutes and you know you then achieve
much greater deeper work the qaol
Newports yeah things I know you've
mentioned before I think yeah yeah the
Cowell Newport book is one that I kind
of I recommend to almost every you know
they're people my colleagues particular
younger academics again a Cal Newport
this is the way to go this is what you
have to do and you can be enormous ly
productive with mine relatively minor
changes its intense work intense break
right it's all or not err on or off I
think an awful lot of the time
especially because a lot of people may
be especially knowledge workers
how many tabs have you got open at once
you're switching between 20 and 25
different tasks at once oh well I'm also
content sourcing for Instagram so social
medias up and I've anyway anyone who's
listening knows just how much I hate the
rabbit hole of cognitive manipulation
that that occurs as soon as you get on
to a onto a social media website but
yeah it's yeah it's multitasking is for
Muppets that's my thing not my approach
it really is yeah there's not a shred of
evidence that you can multitask as
effectively as you can you know the kind
of the intense bursts of productive work
you get from focusing on one thing
that's what we're designed to do where
we are serial we should be serial
focuses rather than doing rather than
trying to multi do multiple things and
it's incredibly satisfying yeah either
taking it taking it off the to-do
listing getting it out of the way is
such a lovely sense of achievement yeah
and I think even just that kind of even
if it's a bigger part of a bigger a
bigger piece of work just knowing that
you've really buried yourself 25 30
minutes done a really intense burst it
is it is incredibly satisfying the whole
and healthy writer I actually did with
the Pomodoro method and I ticked off I
had little circles yeah and every every
circle represented to Pomodoro's and it
was the one thing that looking back and
when I could see 100 of them ticked off
I was gonna say anomaly how many did it
take I think it was about for my bit it
was over a hundred hours of editing but
after the first draft once that once
that had been done but it was kind of it
was incredibly satisfying to see to
color in the boxes and but to know that
each of those was a really valuable I
read a bit piece of the puzzle it was
great what you're saying is that we are
for all that Chris Ryan from sex at dawn
may disagree we are monogamous when it
comes to most optimal workflow approach
we should get we should be monogamous
not polyamorous yeah absolutely
[Music]
a task is for one at a time not for to
it not for two or more at a time yeah
yeah so um you you touched on it there
and one of the
next main issues which people came up
with was an inability to switch off at
night eyes flickering as if you're still
staring at the screen also I strain I
know that my business partner Darrin who
will be listening is just that start
wearing glasses although he actually
manages to pull them off as much as I
wish that he didn't he's had to start
wearing glasses and I think to myself
would he have needed to had we spent the
volume of time that we do in front of a
screen so what what is looking at screen
doing to our eyesight I think the main
thing is I don't know if there's any
evidence that it increases your risk of
refractory problems where you need
glasses but so it made us be he has a
little bit of a something line a
stigmatism which is just giving an extra
problem blind mate darn you would never
you would never ever destined to be able
to see properly I'm afraid no just born
born damaged cursed with that yeah I
think the main thing about showing at
screen is it drives your eyeballs out
they're not like shriveled up the
normally blink about once every five
seconds or something 12 to 15 times a
minute something about the top of my
head I think is the right amount but
when you start staring at a screen you
stop blinking and to the extent you only
blink about sort of five or six times a
minute so once every 10 seconds you're
talking about like a 60% reduction yeah
you mean it's huge and I kind of the
whole thing about tears is obviously
they require to keep your eyes moist and
stop them drying out and they help clear
yeah bugs and it's a not so it's an
important protective mechanism for your
eyes as well is it moisturizing the
cornea on the front of the eye then to a
degree yes certainly there's always that
film of tears across the front of your
eye across in front of your cornea and
if you as anybody your cornea if for
some reason you can't blink you say you
get like a facial nerve palsy a Bell's
palsy where you can you can no longer
close your eyelids properly okay well
one of the priorities for us when we see
something of that is to people have to
tape their eyes shot night and they have
to use artificial tears otherwise the
front of their eye dries out and the
cornea can become quite damaged
ulcerated now I'm not saying staying at
a screen will do that to you but you're
at that kind of point where the bottom
ends the bottom end will be getting
towards it right blinking is important
you know you that's a you know and if
you stop blinking as
then you're not going to your eyes are
gonna feel uncomfortable they're gonna
gritty and irritable and maybe slightly
itchy and just feel just you know like
you got sand with all of that feeling
you know your eyes have been sprinkled
with sand and they just feel dreadful
and so there's a couple of things you
can do that perhaps can reduce eyestrain
one of them is to sit a little bit
further back from your screen so usual
advice is more than I certainly read oh
there was a good study which showed more
than 50 people who sat more than half a
meter away 50 centimetres from their
screen had less eye strain that's
probably about an arm length or so so
and the ridiculous thing about that is
in laptops are bad for this that week as
well it's another way that laptops
damages that we crane over them and I
know there Pratt is practically touching
the screen yeah well the whole point is
because the screen is I'm just looking
at mine now it's 2 inches away from the
top of thee yeah the top of the keyboard
so again if you're not on Bluetooth
Keyboard Bluetooth mouth your mouse your
tethered your tethered your face is
tethered to the front of the screen
very few people tight with their arms
straight out in front yeah and I
wouldn't recommend that either so yeah
designed it to be bad for your eyes in
terms of your eye in that regard um so
so that's really important I kind of
lost my thread now in terms of the eyes
Solutions yeah 57 yeah yes you had to be
more than 50 centimetres away so that's
oh yeah that's what I'm gonna say is the
Hat and use the zoom function you know
how many people are sitting there with
their word document on 100% or whatever
writing software using just crank it up
to two hundred percent two hundred and
fifty percent and sit back a bit there's
no requirement to be close enough to see
the screen all computers have
accessibility features a market within
them so from that regard there's you
just got to learn to delve into the
settings a little okay so which the
screen away from you and um increase
that font size I'm gonna guess a
potential solution for someone who is
maybe looking to go maximum the optimal
of this would be to go for an external
display as well a larger external
display that could potentially be
mounted up on a wall or could be just
raised up with a stand and then you'd
have the the keyboard at where you need
it you could have the the larger display
which allows you if some people feel
like they need to be able to multitask
but also want to have the large size
font you can't you can't have your cake
and eat it with this can you you can't
have lots of things on a small screen
plus all of them be really big or else
you're gonna be what you're gonna be
whizzing whizzing around the screen like
it like a bluebottle
yeah nothing about multi-screen options
are easier and certainly I do that in my
office I've got a PC that sits in my
office and I use whatever it is cable
that connects it up yep DVI adapter and
I have my laptop screen on one side and
em external monitor on the left on the
PC on the other side so I've got a
couple of monitors and you know I can
flick which they're just different
workspaces on the MacBook and so I've
got a two screen option dead easy just
using my laptop that I normally use and
can take home with me yeah dead easy
works really well yeah that sounds great
so can you just tell us the 20-20-20
rule again and why what that's doing in
terms of the the focal length for your
eyes and stuff like that well yeah I
think the whole thing about 20/20 rule
is so every 20 minutes or so take a
break from your screen and stare at
something 20 feet away for 20 seconds
and I think it probably just helps
reduce eyestrain rather than your eyes
being fixed in a sink all the muscles
around the I D ocular muscles been fixed
in one position it just forces you to
contract and move them a little bit as
well so they have to do the work of
pulling open your of changing the focal
length so you focus at a different
distance so it gets them moving but it
probably also just when you look
somewhere else and you move around it
forces you to blink and it makes you
blink now you can cut I've read some
places where it says make sure you blink
every 30 seconds or what-have-you
oh you know blink every 10 seconds and
it will become natural I've find that
hard to believe that it wouldn't be a
constant distraction trying to remember
to blink yes yeah so the trick is just
to change a change where you're looking
a little so you look at something a
little bit different and then now you'll
naturally blink when you do that yeah
and you know you're achieve the goal of
actually blinking a bit but often
moisturizing your eyes giving your foe
giving your muscles a little bit of a
change of perspective focal length which
will just work those ocular muscles a
little and that's likely to reduce the
under eye strain generally so suppose
that ties in again as we've said with
the
Pomodoro Technique of going for the 25
minutes you can do that as part of your
little loop that you do to get up to go
to the bathroom yeah whatever it might
be
yeah absolutely if you don't you don't
have to even think about the 20 20 20
thing if you're doing the Pomodoro
because you're gonna do it naturally
anyway so it becomes it ceases to be a
problem but if you for some reason you
can't get up or you're stuck at a desk
you can't move even just 20 minutes just
doing this thing for sort of 20 seconds
yeah will actually help reduce your eye
strain and the other thing to reduce
your ice cream is get a little get a
little and get some artificial tears get
some eyedrops
you got really you get pretty bad eye
strain eyedrops her absolutely you know
they work they will they will they will
do the that's what we give to people who
can't blink properly or like you know
got facial paralysis
yeah and can't close rile it they they
will do the job okay
so is there a reason why you would get
this the manifestation of eyes
flickering at night as if you're staring
at a screen do you understand what
that's due to no I suspected somebody
you know it's somebody who's just got
too much screen time and is not making
it and it's not reducing I'm I fit most
my senses I don't that I'm not aware of
any sort of specific neurological
problem that that is duty yeah but it
sounds like somebody who desperate needs
to unwind a little and having had
someone who needs to have a narrow
before they go to bed of not looking at
a screen yeah I mean and we haven't
talked about sleeping with we've got a
chapter and sleep in healthy right zone
I mean for me it's a superpower and I
prioritize it now more in my life more
than I have ever done in my whole life
because if I don't sleep right my life
is rotten and if I get my sleep right I
feel great and part of that good sleep
hygiene is turn not looking at my screen
I go to bed at 10:00 my screens go off
at 9:00 Digital Sun sunset right
absolutely and you can do that whole
using flux or those the things that
change the kind of the background
yeah the cue of your screen and I do a
little bit of that as well but actually
you can't be just the off switch is the
way to do it and I think if you really
value asleep then you just got to get
off your devices you know read a book ya
know there was a some really interesting
studies have you read why we sleep
by Matthew Matthew Walker I have yeah
what are you good
anyone anyone who's listening who's
having trouble sleeping before you try
and get hold of melatonin or think that
burning incense or getting a diffuser in
your room is where you need to go by
Matthew Walker's book why we sleep or if
you can't deal with the reading of that
if you want to listen to Joe Rogan
podcast 11 or 9 I know it off by heart
because of how many times I've listened
to him on it it's one of my favorites
and he is he's absolutely fantastic and
the the the summaries that he makes and
the conclusions that he draws about just
how important sleep is to short-term and
long-term health longevity and all the
rest of it is they're terrifying they're
nothing short of terrifying I think I
you know if moving is really incredibly
important getting more exercise but the
three pillars of being healthy are
moving more eating a bit better over
that is but sleep is number it's
absolutely up there as that kind of holy
triumvirate of being healthy and if
you're not getting your sleep right
everything else falls apart and I've got
three kids
they were like they're now a little bit
they're no like 11 12 and 13 but we're
near 1 2 & 3 I wasn't getting a whole
lot of sleep and I just you know my kind
of the difficulties of motivating
yourself to do exercise to cope with
your normal work the kind of the extra
kind of anxiety it provokes and
difficulty level and everything's been
turned metroid' I just cracked you know
obviously the doctor have had some
experience of sleep deprivation and in
the Army they're the army were quite
keen on it as well at times yeah so I've
been through the pain of not sleeping
and life is just so shabby yeah yeah
actually that's why I prioritize it yeah
and there's so many things you can do
which don't require taking medication
the evidence for melatonin is really
weak there's a little bit of evidence in
older people over the age of 55 that it
can help you get to sleep a bit quicker
and you call it your sleeps a wee bit
better but there's not a good evidence
it makes any difference in younger folks
there's potential for resetting
circadian rhythms when traveling as well
right I think it's a good way to hack
jetlag or at least Matthew Walker
alludes to the
the book is the a they've certainly
looked at it hard I'm not sure how good
the evidence is for that either they're
maybe a wee bit yeah I know that's
certainly been tried by a lot of people
some rely on rely on what we know works
which is digital sunset renews reduce
the increase the melatonin response
naturally yeah by not Emily there's like
this whoring in your eyes and a twenty
seconds before you go to the head yeah I
think that's it I think my eyes would be
jumping around a bit and if that were
the case if I did that and I don't my
phone goes on airplane mode at nine and
happy days well I think one of the
anyone who's listening you'll know what
I'm about to say one of my number one
solutions for anybody is to charge the
phone over the other side of the room
and when when you get into your bedroom
as I explained in a hacker in your
pocket podcast and in number 10 with
caiway from the light phone your when
you are in a inertial frame of reference
the likelihood of you staying there when
you're on your phone is greater so use
your phone when you're standing in your
bedroom fine but as soon as you lie down
you're not allowed to have your phone in
your hand because if you're laid down
with your phone in your hand you're
probably gonna let you're probably gonna
stay there and it's more likely you're
gonna stay there than if you were
sitting more likely that if you were
sitting than if you were standing so
charge the phone over the other side of
the room get an alarm clock that doesn't
require you to put an alarm on your
phone yeah both and then your alarm will
go off of the other side of the room and
you've got to get up it blows my mind it
blows my mind that there's an entire
industry of these rug alarm clocks I
don't know you've seen them where you
have to know you have to stand on a
little mat to turn the alarm clock off
I'm like well you could just put an
alarm anywhere else that wasn't next to
the bed and it achieves the same
objective but that's you know I'm not
gonna get sent one of those for free
anymore definitely I think you've blown
it right off their list
yeah I might the thing is if you're a
student and you Reimers your bedroom
sort of thing then absolutely you've got
to deploy something strategies but if
you've got a separate bedroom and don't
let the phone in your room you know
bedroom is a phone free zone yeah that's
I mean that's it that's the absolute
goal right yeah yeah
so moving on hot-desking and university
libraries so you actually you actually
touched on this earlier on if someone
doesn't have the capacity to let's say
her
we customize or build build their ideal
workstation I know that all right in
saying that almost all doctors will be
using shared desks at work well yeah
yeah certainly that a lot will be yeah
it's certainly GPS there's a lot gp's
work part time you gonna be a lot of
premises struggle so you what you are to
a certain extent you you won't have your
own room you'll be going in and out yeah
so what are the carry in your bag or the
I guess the SOS pack of trying to fix
economics for work there yeah so I think
I mean an external keyboard and a mouse
relatively light should be able to I
think you got a notebook I guess it
depends whether you're using your own
laptop in Luke Burke or whether you're
using the you know like say a university
student you know using one of the PCs
and the library or whatever is available
I guess the first thing I'll say is you
don't have to carry anything with you
just to take a moment to you can adjust
the height screen of all of those you
can move things into the correct
position you can adjust the height of
the chair there's actually rather than
just clunking yourself down in you know
whichever you know weirdly proportioned
person was there before you
she's almost definitely not going to be
exactly the same as yourself yes quite
there's actually take the time to make
the adjustments and I just said get
there get the height of that screen so
it's just you know the top of the
screens level with your eyes get they
get the seat at the right height so that
you're kind of your your thighs are like
to be parallel to the ground and your
feet are flat on the floor do those
things first so that you're absolutely
sorted out I think then if you were
doing your own then in terms of working
continuously I would make sure I had
some way of not my phone of preferably
of a little alarm for 20-25 minutes so
that you kind of stick to it I've got a
little watch my watch buzzes so that's
handy in the library I made when I'm at
the University Library it would be cool
if there was a a web-based polidore oh
time I wouldn't though like a
cloud-based one I wonder if I wonder if
someone's come up with that that'll be a
really good if someone needs a business
idea come up with me focus pro for web
browser that would allow notifications
to pop up that would be lovely
yeah yeah that's good thing yeah I've
seen so you need to you need to have a
handy I would and you know if you can I
a notebook rises a little bit of a big
ask I think because they're probably
quite bulky to fit in a bag but if
you've got some books with you may be
able to use them the only thing I'd say
is there are always books in the library
that's a very good point you just got to
go to the new you just got to go to the
new shelf and pull off two or three
books doesn't matter what they are stick
him under your life taking them out no
one's gonna no one's gonna come out
there librarians are put them away again
they're very nice like that
in fact they prefer it if they don't
like it when you put them away they
prefer to do it themselves I like the
work don't they they don't trust they
don't trust students and they definitely
don't trust staff to put them back where
they got them so they're then lost
forever a great term so you can grab a
book so you don't you just use what's
there that's easy and then a little
external keyboard and a mouse and you're
good to go I think I've little bottle of
I um if you're going to you're really
settling in for the long whole yeah then
some eye drops is a good plan is that
really is there an optimal frequency for
using the eyedrops every couple of hours
or during every break is that is that
you're going to end up swimming swimming
into like crying yeah yeah no not
especially the general advice for these
is we put them in every couple of hours
if somebody's got absolutely nothing
going I think it depends how you feel
yeah what one or two hours I don't think
you need every 20 minutes would be a bit
yeah I personally I despise putting eye
drops it's it's never gonna be an easy
task to accomplish is it yeah you're
probably not old enough to remember the
friends episode where they tried to put
eyedrops in Monica for the whole episode
so this is it turns into one of those
for a lot of people okay so I would say
a couple of hours is good don't you okay
so I wanted to talk about some more some
of a slightly more funky solutions that
I've seen which exist for people who
want to really optimize their
workstation and other Johnny another one
of the co-hosts the show he has a really
fancy desk that does both seated and
standing I know that the receptionist at
be fit which is the physiotherapy place
that I go to around the corner sits on a
BOSU ball when I go in she's on have sat
on a big big Swiss ball yeah bouncing
around and I just I wanted to know what
the
efficacy of those particular approaches
are and if there's any others any other
sort of weird and wonderful approaches
you've seen for I know I know Ben
Greenfield has a treadmill office yeah a
treadmill station where he can walk on a
trueform runner at the same time as
dicta and writing and stuff like that
yeah I bet he's quite out there though
he's pretty full on with his self
efficacy stuff I would probably though
this is it's probably worth a very minor
digression is that the evidence is
rubbish for a lot of this stuff it's
really hot and it's not rubbish as in
it's just hard to do good recent medical
research into this kind of thing
because you know you can't do there's no
sort of placebo effect so you can never
quite know what you're with you're
measuring in motivated people who then
feel a bit better or so the evidence is
really hard to pick out right yeah it's
just not good quality and so it makes it
really hard to offer definitive your
chin to anecdote quite quickly and
personal opinion um I would say there's
not an awful lot of evidence for Swiss
polls so that kind of what they could
fall under the category of dynamic
sitting that kind of way you've got to
continually adjust and micro adjustments
when you know kind of using core
strength and to keep yourself in an
upright position I have a Swiss ball in
my room and I don't use it very often
sometimes if I'm a bit bored I'll sit on
it yeah there's some great evidence to
make a huge amount of difference but
it's one of those which I think if you
get relief it does force you to sit any
probably much better you improve your
posture you got it you can't slow John a
Swiss bowl you end up on the floor you
know you're obliged to put your feet
flat down you got a you know you've got
to engage your core you've got to sit up
straight so potentially rather than the
Swiss ball actually being something
magical in and of itself it's just
forcing you into a position that you
could replicate on a normal seat III
would I would think that's almost
entirely ER though I think there is a
there is a kind of evidence there is
research that's gone on around dynamic
sitting to try to work out if it's all
the micro adjustments that makes a
difference I haven't read anything that
really convinced me that there's great
definitive evidence that makes a great
it makes an enormous difference
the other thing then you've kind of been
standing desks as you mentioned I've
also got a standing desk at work I
haven't got a posh one I think I think
there were pictures post at the time
when the book came out last year that
mine was just an old school desk like a
primary school desk should I cut the
legs off and then I whacked a bit of one
inch MDF on the top and I didn't even
nail it together I just rested it on
there and that I find that really I find
that really good I kind of enjoy working
there but I like the variety sometimes I
say it sometimes I stand
sometimes I wall around on my Swiss ball
and sometimes I think that is the kind
of the thing about these slightly wacky
things is that it's just the variety
that is really helpful and makes a
difference to me there isn't and there
is some little bit of evidence for
standup desks in the literature that
they can help in some respects but the
back pain particularly but nothing
nothing really monstrously good okay
actually there's a lot more evidence for
Ben Greenfields treadmill desk ok quite
a few people use and that certainly
seems to be that I've certainly read a
couple of papers one of them showed you
know things like they measure people's
cholesterol and you know kind of blood
glucose to check for diabetes and those
all those sort of markers were quite
significantly improved when someone used
a treadmill desk and but the weirdness
that I mean and I suppose that makes
sense because you're walking so so it's
better than sitting there doing nothing
by a distance yeah and they did also
comment that they noticed that the US
and as I've always thought would be the
problem the treadmill desk uses just
bloomin hard to concentrate when you're
walking yeah on doing something else and
there is oh there was a reduction you
saw a cognitive capacity when you're on
a treadmill desk yeah well you've got
you've got to spend a little bit of
expend some mental force just walking
right not falling over yeah yeah exactly
well you think you're doing automatic
but does require a little bit of effort
yeah it's really good for sort of
relatively low-level tasks you know and
you know Bend when we chatted on this
podcast about it he said exactly that
it's done for answering emails you know
doing other bits and bobs admin tasks
not for the really deep work the qaol
newport sort of really high focus how
Kyle would not be happy with
but walking desk at all if Kyle was here
he would probably absolutely he would be
slapping us yeah the no one would be out
of the window I'm just looking at so I
got hold of the biohackers handbook
which is something been Greenfields
actually affiliated with partway through
that I've got the work addition of this
open there's one on work one and sleep
on a nutrition on an exercise and it is
showing me the effect of body position
on introvert vertebral disc pressure so
a hundred percent disc pressure the
effect of the effect on four postures on
the introvert rebel disc pressure as
measured between the third and fourth
lumbar vertebrae so a hundred percent
when standing if your back angle when
sitting is a 110 degrees so a little bit
leaning back it would be a hundred and
five percent a hundred degrees a hundred
and fifteen percent at ninety degrees at
a hundred and forty percent and at
eighty degrees a hundred and ninety
percent and that's sourced here headsman
tea and fern EG 1997 mechanical response
of the lumbar spine to seated postural
loads yeah so not being in being leaned
forward which i see an awful lot
especially if you look in university
libraries you'll see that people a lot
of the time will naturally
hook their feet under themselves on
yahoo onto the little wheels and they'll
pull themselves right forward do you
know it means other figure yeah they're
not even on the floor they're on top of
the seat on the the base of this air and
then they're leaned right forward apart
from the little bit of assistance you'll
get by having your elbows pushing up
from the desk you're going to be looking
at nearly double the disk pressure we
had which is pretty catastrophic i
imagine well there anything well i've
got a couple of thoughts so the first
thing I'd say is the simple fix for that
is plant your feet on the floor as I
said earlier that kind of that thick
that is the one hack that fixes that
completely because you're right it does
put you into really awkward position the
only thing I'd say is it's a slightly
proxy marker that it doesn't actually
tell you whether you'll get back pain or
give you any problems
can you bus deal with it yeah fine yeah
it's just measuring increase in pressure
during one interval space actually
doesn't necessarily mean it will turn
into anything later on pressure because
actually call- necessarily I but I agree
doesn't I wouldn't wish to underestimate
it it's clearly a pretty rubbish posture
yeah as well and unlikely to quite like
to cause your problems in the longer
term but I'm always a bit wary about the
problem of the research is you can you
see evidence like that but it very but
it's very difficult to translate it into
people who get back pain by you know
later on down the line so the real sort
of clinical endpoints that we're
interested in interesting yeah that is
cool so I wanted to touch on more of the
outside of the day outside of work and
outside of writing health the most sort
of general health as we could call it
and I know that you are a fan of
gratitude journaling based on some of
the bits that I've read about you
I wanted to allow you to elaborate we
haven't touched on gratitude journaling
almost all yet so far although I do do
it I wanted to hear your thoughts on it
and your experiences with it yeah so my
and one of the things we want to do with
the book was just to point out that
writing in particular wasn't all just
catastrophic ly bad for your health
there was a slight danger that the book
was just going to be immediately it's
horrific and one of the clearest bits of
evidence about writing was writing is I
mean there's certainly some medical
stuff about writing his therapy and
people with mental health problems and
other things but actually for just
thinking for people in general and for
the wider population there's something
everybody can do gratitude journaling
has a really pretty decent it has has
some decent evidence that underpins it
and it goes back to some California and
psychologists who looked into this Emma
and McCullough and they there was an
experiment it goes I think it was back
to 2003 at the early 2000s sometimes
like some time like that and they they
ran one of these studies that
psychologists love to do and they got
the participants to write down just a
few things that they were grateful for
every day whether that was the you know
the kindness of a friend or a beautiful
sunset and incredibly they only had to
write a sentence and they only had to do
it once a week so what's really not a
big asset so in the
right yeah that is really you know the
biggest problem that would be
remembering a do it because it's so low
yeah it's absolutely tiny and they found
that it really seems that they stopped
they found some clear improvements in
well-being for those people and that
they felt better but really interim one
of the things that really piqued my
interest about that study is because I'm
I can be a little bit cynical about some
of these psychologists psychology
studies they're often got very low
numbers and you know you got to be
careful about how far you draw your
inferences with them yes but they also
they also found evidence that the the
families of the participants had noted
that their loved ones were seemed to be
better in themselves and they had
improved well-being and I thought that
was route that was a really interesting
kind of nugget as part of that that
really kind of for me gave this a lot
more credibility and at the the
California psychologists have gone on to
do more studies and there's some
Manchester psychologists who've also
looked into this and a host of others
but what they also found so they also
found that there was good evidence that
doing a gratitude journal could improve
your sleep okay two strengths I see
improved asleep so it feeds exactly back
into what we were saying before they and
if you have better sleep and you sleep
longer well creycrey I mean that is you
can you know the effects that Matt
Walker have talked about has talked
about in his book that means that you're
less likely to get cancer you're less
likely to have a heart attack
okay less like you're less likely to
have a stroke or Alzheimer's yeah so
actually there is incredible power if a
very simple intervention like a
gratitude journal can reduce your
anxiety can help you to sleep a little
bit better there is I mean you've got to
be a bit careful about pulling this
chain out too far the air downs
downstream where do you where do you
stop yeah but there is if it makes you
feel better at the time then that's a
pretty good place to start and because
you know people are not very good at
doing stuff that will keep them at get
make them live six months longer when
they get to 70 they're good at doing
stuff that makes them feel good at the
time and I think that's the lot of the
experience of doing a gratitude journal
that I've found and a lot of people have
found is that it just helps you feel a
little bit better about your life helps
you it gives you a more positive slant
on life
and it reduces that sort of stress and
anxiety it was an interesting an
interesting point that yusuf made on one
of the last podcasts where the typical
experiment he says look around your room
for something red now close your eyes
and tell me what in the room is blue
because the reticular activating system
focuses for it narrows in right and his
his argument was that something similar
was going on that it's very difficult to
hold anxiety in the mind at the same
time as searching I my gratitude journal
I'll hold my hands up and say that some
mornings finding something which isn't
what I wrote about the the day before or
just the first thing that comes to mind
I am grateful for the taste of coffee I
am grateful for you know it can be it
can be moderately challenging some days
to come up with something which is
meaningful but that search for what is
what does have meaning to me today what
am i genuinely grateful for today it
forces an awful lot of worries out it's
very difficult to hold both of those
things in the same moment yeah that may
be exactly what's going on now I've
certainly haven't looked too hard into
what the psychologists think I mean it's
one of those things that people who get
depressed and anxious often have
intrusive negative thoughts and kind of
ongoing difficulties breaking out of
that cycle of negativity and you know
that's the whole basis of something like
CBT really is to help link how you think
with how you behave with how you feel
and break some of those barriers down
and I wonder sometimes if gratitude
journals just start to nudge that along
a little bit they're an almost like an
initial step perhaps with the the bit
you mentioned about actually holding
negative thoughts and you had at the
same time for those who haven't got as
far as you know having full-blown
depression or anxiety kind of problems
is that they're just a really simple
little hack it's nice it's nice you'd
admit every morning yeah I do yeah so
I've got I'll put a link in the show
notes to the six minute diary which is
scandalously a ripoff of the five minute
journal but is is better as far as I'm
concerned it's by a company called your
best self
it's available it's available ok the
link the link will be in the description
but it's three minutes on the morning in
three minutes at night three three
things you're grateful for it's the
first thing you do in the morning and
yeah it's it's interesting it helps to
bring into perspective on more of a
direct level from what you're actually
writing when you do a gratitude journal
I find that it is brought more sharply
into perspective things which I am
actually grateful for when surprise
surprise
but it's interesting what those are
because a lot of the time you look back
at your day and you think what did I do
with my day which produce something
which I was grateful for the next day
and it's never I'm grateful for gaining
a thousand followers on Instagram I am
grateful for this it's it's stuff like
I'm grateful for the incredibly
meaningful message that someone sent me
about the last week's podcast episode
I'm grateful I'm grateful for the
message that my mum sent yesterday or
that I got to spend I get to spend this
afternoon off and I get to go and see my
friends or do you know I mean it reminds
you of what you should be spending your
time doing because when when you're
alone with your thoughts with nothing
else to distract you these are the
things which percolate to the surface
yeah it's interesting so I think for
such a little simple thing it's got this
quote it's probably there's quite a
complex set of consequences of doing it
that it triggers often it you know it's
probably it's working across multiple
mechanisms very interesting to work it
out a yeah I think it's and it probably
buries persons person that's the thing
as well if you know kind of in terms of
you say breaking sometimes that negative
cycle just sometimes getting it to focus
on the important things
just sometimes letting go of the petty
trivial irritations that you're letting
dominate your thoughts really incredibly
useful it provides a lot of perspective
so I want you to I want it to give you
we haven't touched that much on writers
per se but I know I have a access to a
swath of us romance authors who
hopefully will give a little a little
cheer that that they've got a shout out
there and I know for a fact that a lot
of them suffer with writer's block
right and I wondered if you had any
strategies for people who are
potentially content creators potentially
writers maybe on a blog maybe authors as
I've said and they're attacking either
high volume or high frequency workloads
of writing are there any strategies
which you employ to try and get around
writer's block I'm not sure I've no I
don't think I've ever suffered from
writer's block as such where I've just
sat down and not been out to write
anything and I know that a lot of its
perhaps a slightly contentious area
isn't it that some people would claim it
doesn't exist
there certainly I've suffered from you
know if if procrastination is a is a
subset of right oh absolutely class
under that yeah yeah then I've suffered
from that to the enth degree and and
there's nothing like I guess one of the
best strategy I had was having a
co-author because it's and I'm kind of
you know as a as a particular I guess
it's a Medic thing as a doctor we were
it's very hot we all can have you have
all this academic path and you pass
exams and you're always wanting to
please people that were not very good at
not doing what's expected of us in some
ways so when I've got a commitment to
somebody else and I guess that's one way
of doing and you could do that
commitment whether it's you've got a
co-author or whether you make that
commitment publicly that's a route
that's probably a really good way for me
to be procrastination a proper hard
deadline external accountability
absolutely is what really does it for me
when it comes to getting over
procrastination getting over that kind
of subset of writer's block that's the
one that I have the most experience with
and you know I still suffer with on a
daily basis there's always you know
could always tart up a website a little
bit rather than actually writing some
proper content for it and it's just
there kind of that um and that's just
that that's another it's not like I'm
sitting around like going to bed because
I'm procrastinating out so I'm finding
other petty jobs it's the low-hanging
fruit rather than the deep work right
yeah exactly and I guess it feeds right
back into that is only to go away and
read Cal Newports book again yeah to
remind myself how the hell to get down
to some proper serious work yeah I
understand
well you and I really I really
appreciate today I think we've
attacked a problem which is incredibly
widespread anyone who is listening will
have spent that at some portion of their
last day sat in front of a laptop and
yeah for those people who are spending a
lot of time there hopefully we've
managed to provide some some solutions
can you tell the listeners where they
can find you online yeah so the best
place to find me is and I have my
website is www.seannal.com line the best
place to connect with me is you can get
to me by a bloke ology or just on
Twitter so that you and underscore loss
and that's you aan underscore la WS o n
fantastic thank you very much for your
time you and I'll make sure that the
links to blow ecology your Twitter your
podcast as well which is fantastic I'll
make sure the links to all of that are
in the show notes below but thank you
very much for your time it's been a
pleasure now my pleasure entirely Chris
thank you thank you very much
[Music]